you
I'm going to try an all-out berserk with
this one this is the Wrigley Tournament
a three to three check forty minutes
so means I have a minute thirty in no
increment
which maybe isn't too bad of a handicap
for this variant it's one where you
could kind of get away with it
that doesn't seem like the right star
let's do this first
if the bishop blocks I get to take the
knight I got one check if I want it I
want it I only need two I maybe could
look all ready for this
threatening a mountain to striking at
the heart if this Knight moves it's game
over game over that's their check back
to turn three
the timing was just right I think this
is one of the first three check
tournaments I am playing in and
recording one that I didn't create
Wrigley all right so we have what four
other ones don't forget to preserve
efore this is already close to losing
for block maybe a bit uh seems a bit new
maybe at the old question mark still
provisional that's one check this is
already winning Queen will be able to
deliver that third and final check can't
stop that one there's nowhere to run
it's going to do it that's a third one
back determinate land what I was on
berserk why didn't I get three for that
oh that has happened before if the game
ends too quick you don't get the full
three what are the rules on that someone
fill me in the chat like you have to get
to X number of moves in order to get to
full three for the berserk pretty sure I
clicked on it and I got two points for
that one
that was five moves pretty sure you have
to make it to a move ten threatening one
check this isn't a this isn't the the
way to test you know what White's doing
with their pieces it should really be e4
on move 1.e4 every time I think that's
the most testing
okay so I'm getting word berserk only
grants an extra point if you play at
least seven moves in the game you know
what I'm going to have to take that into
account maybe I should have just not one
as quick as I did now I don't know if I
could say that much let's go with this
anticipating this let's stop him from
going any further
I'll deal with one Bishop check that's
not a good investment to give a full
piece for that check
Viking will be secure enough that moves
enough to just scare me away into a
castling kingside
and how about how about we start with
this give him a boot let's jump in 54
seconds on III I'll play this move I'd
like to have the file opened up just
going to do this
it's getting pretty crazy on the bishop
looking to capture it with check
probably not best what I'm doing here
Bishop takes I have a check here
there's rook takes pawn isn't there and
I could take that bishop here I have
this e I want to
King here that I want to get my rock on
a che
that's a pretty good move I don't think
that night could hurt me though boo
wife Queen takes pawn they don't have
any checks neither of us have any checks
just yet I have both my rooks playing I
kind of view it like that this is tricky
bruiser King okay they only need two
more checks but I have one check here
not having the increment hmm
rook h1
gonna be too but I want to look more
just this stuff I guess Kings seat King
f2 46 seconds
being able to rely on my opponent
running out of time something other than
king of something other than queen f2
here what am i doing on that move
exactly be careful okay
this should not be working it could take
the queen with check and then give a rip
check for a second check and then a
third check unavoidable so I got this
one once then seven here's one two one
more three back to tournament okay got
ten thirty two minutes left
thirty seven players in this one I see
platypus Jedi chess dog the guy who gave
me a beating in horde chess Riki remedy
who is a new player and likely a tough
opponent I have him right now still a
provisional playing the French not a bad
oh I forgot to bring arc
% / zerk okay all right well I'm just
not going to berserk any of the other
games I don't know man
not cool I got distracted
talking about him being provisional oh
yeah there's that move let's do that
let's do that
yeah hmm might be able to do something a
little wacky because I have already
given one check suppose i play my knight
in to e5
no no no no you're going to go here and
Knight takes rook you go here kick the
clean off of this diagonal and then look
for queen bee 5 and then checkmate a
third check jumpyluff in the chat you
are very welcome
glad you are enjoying the content and
you are now hosting thank you for the
host ah you know I'm not used to berserk
ensue I've only done a hundred percent
berserk and one of the tournaments that
I've recorded so okay be careful now be
careful because black is lining up check
check and then this I could start with
this poof
you
hmm to be pretty careful if I do this
night check
you
Bishop check how it
take back it's a good thing it's a good
thing I didn't preserve this game ah
I took a good time to forget okay Manna
Dey let's let's figure this out
d4 you can always go d4 and then no and
I want to allow this night to be
captured with Chuck hmm interesting
Wow okay I think this is a good move
side steps on night move with check side
steps of Bishop check and I'm
threatening this takes takes Bishop here
okay they're going in for that I don't
believe that that's working now because
of this move and I win the Queen if she
moves I have check and then I get the
third and final still messy because they
could Castle and then look for something
to open up against my king yeah it's
still very difficult for me their king
is going to be safe do I even have to
capture the Queen I should be able to do
this stuff look for a capture here and
then checkmate let's take the Queen
let's start with this maybe not a wise
choice
oh boy yikes
hmm see the bishop covers that all right
they might be able to
one check here they could do something
like this
I just I want a little bit more security
for my king this night might want
oh I only have four point four seconds
okay they still don't have a check
against me I don't know if I should even
waste any time trying to pick up the
night seven seconds
bishop here could still take the pawn
17 seconds 15 no no no looking for mate
by regular means there is no ruck here
five seconds rook takes pawn rook takes
Bishop yeah they resigned I was going to
be able to get those final two hmm okay
yeah as mentioned I'm not going to do
any more berserks
I'm just going to play it out I wanted
to do all of them berserk I'm just going
to treat all games like that last one
regardless okay uh who's this this is
the number two guy I got 14 he has 12
okay 24 minutes left in this one okay
I've been here before if you watched a
stream or the videos I post with the
three check this is of this is
development with tempo very very useful
to get this in it's already difficult
enough for black in three check you know
there's a lot of time being wasted and
let's go here now you here I'll castle I
don't want Knight takes bishop wits
check castling there's these ideas 'if
I've even the night drifting over here I
want to get castle before any of that
though
let's castle looking to give him a boot
and then jump over here let's do it
this is winning I think well I'm certain
its winning actually he up I think this
is working with just regular chess
Knight g5 Queen h5 this is a second
check yep that was the idea with the
bishop posting up here initially I
thought of going here to delimit 8a
bishop for night as I tend to give more
weight to the night over the bishops and
you know just whatever you know let's go
here I think this was working too you
know they resigned back to tournament we
have got 18 though still with fire
eighteen twelve eleven ten forty two
players are now in this one he's a new
player as well that last guy that I
played I think he just kind of had the
wrong idea that early point um okay see
uh batter bombs in there I think he just
finished we might even get paired up
again will probably be the colors
reversed this time around I'll have to
play with black should make for an
interesting game out that one was that
was an interesting one no not getting
paired up with him so mtv2 to seven
start with c5 you know what I found
playing in stock fish in Street check me
playing as white again stock fish stock
fish would play an opening sequence with
knight c6 and d5 normally you don't want
to touch your D pawn but deploys the
knight first stopping this checking idea
okay
um I'm going to do this I like this idea
I think white could go just like an e5
move I'm doing this as a gambit strictly
a gambit here I'm giving this pawn up
and my idea here is to play maybe it's
not a gambit maybe this is just good for
me so the knight moves I'm taking here
checkmate this is actually a trap isn't
it I know I just I played this idea
before but I think maybe white was
already castled but now the night is
just pinned down c3 is necessary yeah
play c3 here must yeah I think you must
play c3 here bishop crashing through an
f2 is too much so I can also have this
move in I don't see any reason not to go
straight in for that right now
could add more fuel to this Knight Queen
b6 is now all the more appealing
only after the b-pawn is moved tucked
behind the pawn not obstructing the
b-pawn and I learn a little bit more
about the bishop chooses to stay here
Queen b6 or Knight f6 both are
interesting
I'm gonna go with Knight f6 because
because why what am i doing on e5 now
I'm thinking I should go here to stop
the Queen from coming out to put
pressure on this pawn hmm interesting
moment I could think about Queen coming
out myself actually yeah I'm leaning
more towards this striking at e4
threatened you take upon with check and
now only this and this Knight I believe
is still pinned you know as an example
castles Knight f6 Knight f3 takes takes
takes takes checkmate explosion on f2 so
I probably have to castle or well I
guess developing the Queen is sufficient
but soon I'm going to be doing this okay
that opens this diagonal I can already
get two checks and now I'm once again
threatening mate check check can't
recapture in that position because
that's the third and final let's see
fishing pole ideas are quite strong in
some cases and I might be able to do
that
h5 Knight g4 if he's ever captured
there's no surviving that Queen checks
rook checks alright so they're stopping
these sacrifices on f2 but I could sneak
in deeper with Queen h3 and you know
let's do that no light-square bishop
around to dislodge my queen
two gaps here two holes f3 h3 and no
minor piece around to remedy them okay
this Knight is maybe a bit closer to
being back on full strength bishops
unprotected some tactical issues against
this guy tempted to play Knight g4 but
I'm afraid of a some sacrifice here Wow
a one-minute maybe I should just castle
let's just castle there's something
going on here like this well no maybe
not on this I could take the bishop now
if my king was still here
Knight takes Bishop takes there's Knight
moves with check okay so I guess
preparing to go clean side huh
okay let's go here they're threatening
these ideas they're in a pin here the
pawn on e4 Castle the knight is pinned
otherwise I'm taking with Czech so I'm
going to keep this pin look to improve
somewhere else Knight g4 maybe b4 to
open up this wing this is very appealing
looking to take upon wits check okay
that's one check they missed that and if
I'm not mistaken I could actually take
here Queen takes Queen Bishop takes pawn
check no no no no let's not make it
complicated here you're taking there
with check and that's a third and final
back to tournament land we are at 22
less than 15 deejay chess dog okay start
with e 6
hmm isn't that a mistake
think you're supposed to play Knight
here first
so that you can meet Bishop here with
this I don't think that this is working
I have two different checks
so I need to win upon and also just land
a third second check and I think I only
need to invite one more piece my queen
and that should be good enough I'm going
to run and hide I could do that
2:22 for the chest dog oh we haven't
played yet
where's game here let's do that first
let's take here no okay well they're not
going to get made at anytime soon mmm
now let's go here hmm
well
sacrifices here I learned that oh but
wait
night f2 that's a star move isn't it
Knight have to
Queen f3 Knight h3 check King f1az
otherwise Queen g5 so here
Queen f3 threatens me by regular means
night up to Queen f3 Knight h3 check
King f1 I think I'm running out of fuel
don't think that that's working so I'm
going to try it first with this just to
defend here and well I'm threatening
scholars made style checkmate
watch out for f2 watch you don't get
have to okay get that bug I back he's
not going to bother why I'm down a piece
yeah I think this was a poor decision by
me oh I'm threatening this win boom and
then boom though I have a threat here
careful making to threat at one king
this is easily missed something like
this
alright you forget okay that puts an end
to it let's challenge that night I'll
Castle if he tries this sorry capture
my king is a pretty safe hmm try and
Bishop here hmm I dare you I dare you
give me an open line okay good enough
good enough okay that's a pretty scary
move I think I need to stop the knight
from getting here yupper I have so many
dark square weaknesses it's not even
funny
oh man and they have a dark square
bishop hmm okay uh how about about that
we're looking at this stuff
Wow very bold very very bold I don't
think you could survive this now Rick
here next Bishop is going to back up
comes the H bone okay
tight game in very tight game hmm Wow
well let's do this
captures no threatening some sacrifices
here one day maybe let's open it up
I got another check hmm let's just open
things up I'll need one more check okay
here comes one more check there it is
well I got to rethink that initial
sacrifice because my opponent put a lot
of resistance up I don't think I think
if I did that against the computer I'm
not even coming anywhere close to to
getting a third check Wow
yeah I got to rethink that one an early
Bishop c5 and then capture enough - yeah
I don't think it's right I don't think
it's right okay you know seven minutes
left I have an eight-point lead 26 and
then 18 happy to have light okay I'm
going to go for this and
just have this um I've learned some more
yeah this isn't working although I did
lose a game I did lose a game in a term
I wasn't recording but I had this very
thing happen I'm investing upon just to
get one check in there I ended up losing
a game where I started out just like
this
my opponent pulled off a nice
combination
involved a queen sac totally overlooked
it so what's not let's not let that
happen again how should we really be
treating this position we're going to
start with this if that Knight moves I
may very well invest a bishop to get a
second check he doesn't concern me
especially since when I counsel I'm on a
dark square so really we might say that
in three check the Queen bishops are not
nearly as dangerous at least early on as
the King bishops who can be coming out
in hitting at squares and giving cheque
to the enemy King follow
let's start with castles I did think
about d4 straight away just to open
lines up
yeah I might have
do that unprovoked and I'll baby step it
here 95 94
yeah I think it's well worth a pawn
investment to land a check well worth it
okay so now how about Bishop g5 our
Knight g5 I like Knight g5 actually here
and here is just not going to be enough
fuel
if this Knight moves I'm guaranteed a
second check with the knight and likely
a third and final check with the Queen
you could usually rely upon a knight and
a queen if they're in a good enough
position to deliver a check even the
rooks be the most deficient pieces the
bishop
we got 340 on the tournament clock
batter bombs is within five maybe he's
researching one of his games but I think
if I get this one getting up to thirty
should be sufficient enough hopefully
his game doesn't finish too soon okay
and I think I'm okay with this trade who
could get the rooks active first plus I
mean we're entering opposite color
bishop bending so you know these are not
the most healthy of pawns these three
all hover and easy enough time
restricting these four okay
probably this hmm
know what Bishop g4 is a bit annoying
let's just develop and pinpoint this
pawn so I still have that one check in
there this is good I'm looking to also
maybe control this file if I could get
here
concerns me that when a rook plays here
they're threatening to take my rook with
check I think I want to be in a spot to
play king h2 let's do this I'm going to
I'm going to opt for some King security
and this is a fine shelter for him and
certainly the correct color flight
square so let's get here rook takes rook
is no longer hitting with check and I
believe at this point b6 is a good idea
well they're not going for that so what
does this mean it means I get to control
this file there at 10 seconds by the way
in the clock time 1:22 I still have that
five point lead are they going to lose
on time you go upon hunting no it spawns
in the way ok what to do let's just get
this pun out of the line of fire also I
could look to clamp down now let's do
that it goes here I have this check ok
interesting
I don't know feels active
hmmm let's go here I don't think I
my bishop controlling the square anymore
my rook is now super active I have these
ideas where is that King going put
pressure on this pawn rook check hmm
they're playing with fire oh and there's
not enough time on still he did berserk
and he had five they still had me up top
there so the tournament's over I think
I'm gonna win on tiebreaks
oh just noticing that he did preserve
and win all right let's see if I can
make no no no no no yeah we're going to
do that
alright I'm gonna try something else
let's come back here
this isn't repetition of position is it
you just make a move here to make sure
they don't now what happened
automatically if it's a repetition what
am I talking about I'm under 20 seconds
better get a move on and try something
else huh mmm don't know if that's a good
idea I'm threatening a check though oh
they missed out it's a second check and
that's a third and final whoo first
place only on tiebreaks Wow he did brick
that kam he was involved in it's the
right thing to do but uh just got him on
tiebreaks their batter bombs levy gun
was in third me was in fourth
Ricky remedy probably the most
interesting game from the tournament I
can't say that now though because the
game against DJ chest dog was pretty
interesting and so too was that last one
we had some interesting ones 48 players
and all let's see everyone else page two
three four and five okay to the 47 of
you who took part in ridley tournament
it games all right